allez on va aller sur un gros nid de
frelons asiatiques
regardez-moi ça
comment il est et non si l'on compare
avec ma main
ce joli petit front bouffe nos abeilles
est vraiment invisible très important en
france
[Musique]
maïté s'implique vraiment fort
j'ai pu
reprendre asiatiques la lecture de freud
en sont plus douloureuses que la piqûre
de guêpe ou d'abeille qu'on a en europe
ça c'est une certitude après l'autre ces
douleurs et par lien avec
les estimations pour mourir l'embellie
nations s'était passé 500 pur dépasser
500 piqûre c'est vraiment exceptionnel
il faut vraiment vraiment les personnes
qui ont coupé en deux avec intérêts par
exemple on sentira général et une
quarantaine de zéro pour jeannette un
bon le pro long du coup pharmacie et
tous les anti allergique elle est la
cortisone on a pas de cas d'envenimation
donc de mort par vraiment vraiment ce
qu'on a commencé par des réactions
allergiques une réaction énergique il
rase ou peut être allergique à partir de
la deuxième piqûre différents shows que
sévère et à mourir et là il faut agir
effectivement que c'est très rare que
nous mais c'est toujours la même chose
avec les domestiques
la première chose à faire c'est
d'ailleurs pas paniqué qu'ils ont une
réputation la gueule si ce ne sont pas
il faut vraiment géré aller chercher
pour tu piques et comme toute espèce
social il va attaquer surtout pour
défendre sa collègue considère une
licence de sécurité de 5 m est largement
suffisante si vous vous faites quelque
chose que l'arrêt n'est pas dedans ou
tout simplement de vous casser lit et
bâle a rien à lire à faire là ni
ailleurs vous ne le verrez pas et c'est
là au mois de juillet août et septembre
pour les nids seront de taille colossale
que vous allez le contacter en disant il
ya énormément de frelons et les lits
seront très dangereux idéal ces dons et
ses photos si on a un ami c'est plus
intéressant pour les actions et dans
tous les cas c'est le signaler à sa
mairie en charge en partie les coûts de
destruction merrick normalement relais à
l'organisme local on va traiter là on va
piquer à plusieurs endroits
il est dernier frôlant elles vont mourir
petit à petit écoutons valeurs
conseillées forcément dépassé lesquels
sur le rocher pour capturer le frelon et
d'une impression de prédation mais c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui concerne les
apiculteurs et cours des conseils à
grande échelle
le frelon d'europe qui va se promener et
attraper ce qu'il a trouvé sur son
chemin et en général quand il passe
devant une ruche forcément il ya des
abeilles à longer be va attendre un
petit peu et attraper une abeille en
passant si l abeille sortent pas mais
rentrer c'est que dominique bâillon par
contre que venant agrestic lui qui l'a
rester en vol stationnaire devant la
route chaque étape et si tout se passe
bien nous attrape cobain serait devant
la route vraiment qu'on a c'est que
notre abeilles ne sortant plus mais il
faudra se retrouver le nombre à l'entrée
de la ruche est ce qu il a encore plus
d'une et les aides qui vont encore moins
sentir bien seul pour qu'ils amplifient
encore le phénomène de paralysie dollar
on a le frelon d'europe qui est vespa
crabo qui est une espèce qui est
présente naturellement en france qui a
scié les barreaux il est majoritairement
20 ou plus tôt et surtout l'abdomen qui
a rayé de noir exo le front oriental
c'est notre espèce de faux noms qui est
plutôt sud de l'europe n'étaient pas
présents en france avait été détectée
l'année dernière à marseille c'est un
faux nom qui est à peu près la même
taille que flou d'europe qui est
entièrement roual existe un petit anneau
jaune citron sur l'abdomen et le frelon
asiatique c'est un faux nom qui vient
d'asie chine qui est un trou du diable
commerciaux horticole en france
normalement avant 2004 c'est un petit
peu plus petit peut être deux espèces de
fond qu'on avait en europe et qu'il est
quasiment entièrement noir avec un
anneau bien visible orange sur l'abdomen
et l'extrémité des pâquis
en 10 15 ans il a quasiment colonisé au
tout le territoire français
mécaniquement partout en dehors de la
course
il atteint presque climatique en
fait qui permettrait de
deux ans et d'éradiquer toute la
population les modèles qu'on fait des
collègues
dont il faudrait tuer plus de 90% des
colonies tous les ans pour 10me la
population de 50 cent dix ans
donc c'est les moyens colossaux pour des
résultats qui sont deux ans par contre
vu les méthodes combat aujourd'hui
notamment détection en corse on peut par
exemple envisager protéger la course
s'il faudra détecté suffisamment
précocément encore son droit peut-être
le cir détecter les premières colonies
en mettant beaucoup de moyens et
en fait ça reste un prédateur
les prédateurs cd régulateur de d'autres
espèces notamment de l'espèce qui
pullulent le frelon asiatique se
développe très bien en france parce que
le mieux en fait les garder mais très
favorablement cette espèce et que ses
proies favorites vont être lavés
domestique est en forte densité et deux
autres espèces l'équipe qu'on va
favoriser ondine le gall qui nous
dérange aussi plus que le frelon
asiatique pour la majorité des gens donc
c'est un prédateur il a un rôle voire de
régulation l'espèce qui sont on va dire
surdensité l'incertain de millas pour
nous laver des médecins qui ont mené à
bien qu'elles soient reçues avant
c'était pour prévenir que de moi
[Musique]